in Upstate New York they're still
testing the depth of this crisis these
are pictures from Buffalo with streets
eagerly empty as the city waits for the
snow to subside
there have been dozens of fatalities and
the number is expected to rise the
clear-up is in part a casualty count it
is uh painful to find members of your
community that are deceased are those
that are deceased actually on streets in
our community who are trying to walk out
during storm conditions got disoriented
and passed away out in the street tens
of thousands of people remained without
power for yet another day in New York
state President Biden pledged federal
funds for affected areas as more snow
was forecast they have been out there
talking them personally about their
experiences going into homes going into
vehicles and and too many tragic times
of finding people who did not survive
the experience and I want them to know
that we know that is difficult work to
do and they're grieving inside as we all
are for the families who are getting the
horrible heartbreaking news that their
loved ones succumbed to the storm over
the last day or two I want people to
understand there's a lot of roads that
are completely blocked right now that
have no access whatsoever
and people are trying to drive into on
these roads or trying to get into these
neighborhoods and they can't
please
please you heard the mayor beg I'm
begging stay home
travel chaos living helping people and
Beyond this was the scene at San Diego
airport where the baggage was going
nowhere and neither were passengers
canceled flights have stranded thousands
across the country
these are pictures from Buffalo as the
Buffalo Bills football team and staff
dug out their vehicles it provided one
measure of snowfall delivered by the
Arctic blast though ultimately the storm
that straddled Christmas will be defined
by its destruction and death
James Matthews Sky News in Washington